Hello everyone, welcome to today's meeting.
Thanks for having me. I'd like to start with the Q4 roadmap.
Great, let's dive in. What are the top priorities?
The analytics dashboard redesign is our primary focus for this quarter.
I agree with Sarah. We should also consider the API integration work.
Good points. Let's break this down into specific action items.
I can take the lead on the dashboard. Michael, can you handle the API side?
Absolutely, I'll coordinate with the backend team.
Perfect. Sarah, what's the timeline looking like for the dashboard?
I'm estimating about six weeks for the initial release. We'll need design reviews at week two and four.
The API work should align well with that. I can have the endpoints ready by week three.
Excellent. Any blockers we should discuss?
We need final sign-off on the design specs from the product team.
And I'll need access to the staging environment for testing.
I'll follow up on both of those today. Anything else before we wrap up?
I think we're good. Thanks everyone!
Thanks, talk soon.